lowry's the prime rib is taking the
christmas spirit to the next level
starting today they will have victorian
style christmas carolers serenading
guests and joining us now are carolers
kayla olivia tim and daniel welcome
thank you so much so what can guests
expect when they walk into the
restaurant well first of all you can
expect a beautiful ambiance when you
come in the fire is going the tree is
lit and wonderful service and a gorgeous
prime rib dinner oh i'm so excited so
when it comes to performing are you
performing at tables you have a stage
how do the performances work well the
where there will be a quartet in one
room there's three different rooms at
lowry's so no matter which room you're
seated in you will have a carol
experience and the carolers are singing
to the entire room if you'd like to make
a special request then we'll come right
to your table and you're not the only
part of the uh part of the decor i mean
lowry's is truly decked out for the
holiday season as well it is beautiful
trees beautiful lights and just that
smell of that great food all right
so you guys ready to perform
all right this is going to be very
special lowry's the prime rib victorian
christmas carolers uh they're appearing
nightly starting tonight through
december 24th at lowry's the prime rib
[Music]
[Music]
what fun it is
[Music]
oh
oh